it's cool to see a fellow friend
of mine and a guy that's playing the
same position as me um have so much
success it's definitely dope it's going
to be a good experience like you said we
played earlier this year was was a it
was a good game went back and forth and
it's just too
two good teams going head to head and
you know we're just trying to you know
be the best we can for our team and help
our team win you've watched desean since
college i'm sure even since high school
they're never out of a game i mean
someone that can make big plays happen
no matter what the scenario is he's not
he's gonna fight until the end and so
you know that going into the game
two of the great quarterbacks in the nfl
i almost said great young quarterbacks
no two of the great quarterbacks in the
nfl really in my mind there are three
mvp finalists this year lamar jackson
patrick holmes deshaun watson the first
voice you heard was desean watson then
it was patrick mahomes they were picked
back to back what about russell wilson
you're going to throw him in there right
i
by the time the season ended i think it
was for those guys it was those three
yeah okay i get you but uh but you've
got i will throw them in there you've
got deshaun watson you've got patrick
mahomes getting together in the
postseason we're always looking for that
next peyton manning tom brady rivalry
and there's a chance
this could be it right this could be the
first playoff game between two guys who
are going to be crossing paths every
year in the regular season if they keep
winning their divisions and then
possibly every year every other year
every third year in the playoffs so this
is this is a great great matchup on
sunday great great matchup these two
guys got everything
i mean they have all the makings to like
what you're saying to where we this
could be the first of eight or nine
matchups in the playoffs who knows i
would not be shocked i mean both are
extremely talented
both understand the game both can make
plays you know off schedule both are
smart and can dissect defenses and make
the right decisions you know both have
the great
demeanor i think that's where i look at
them that's where i'm so impressed with
some of these units like you're saying
some of these young quarterbacks that
have come into football over the last
two years you know they're just unfazed
by it it's just like oh okay it's late
in the fourth quarter and i got to drive
down i used to do this in madden all the
time so what's the big difference if
it's a real life i mean it's really it's
that's how i feel they they feel
sometimes but uh so talented and you
know what do you think
is this a better quarterback matchup to
you than rogers and wilson is this the
one you're more like just as far as the
quarterbacks are concerned would you
rather watch these two or those two i
would rather watch
i think wilson and rogers because
we're not going to have as many of those
there yeah it's kind of the yeah every
one of these big games with aaron
rodgers we're getting closer and closer
to the last big game yeah okay and i
feel like we're going to have a
generation of watson and homes and i
also feel like the two teams are more
tightly
balanced on sunday afternoon no evening
the late game seahawks packers than the
earlier game i just feel like the chiefs
are the better team yeah the defense is
far better than it was when they played
in week six and texans somehow won in
kansas city so i think i i'm leaning on
the side of wilson and rogers yeah i i
hear that i mean uh but they could
change if they have a great game if
there's a great showdown and they lay
the foundation for more and more of
these games and we're gonna look back to
this one and say that's where it all
started well i know you're right well i
think we could see more exciting plays
from mahomes and watson at this point of
their careers maybe compared to wilson
and rogers and that's saying a lot
because you know i think those two are
like borderline houdinis themselves but
interesting matchup and the best passer
of the four the best passer of the four
i think i would have to go with patrick
mahomes and you know that hurts me to
say that about my buddy aaron rodgers
but yeah i think patrick patrick mahomes
has
maybe
passed him up this year i do i think for
the first time ever i'm going to go into
an offseason and go you know aaron
rodgers is not the best quarterback in
football and that's the first time since
maybe 2009 that i'll feel that way i'd
hate to say i hate to see what you'd be
saying about aaron rodgers if he wasn't
your buddy i mean every chance you've
had the last two i haven't said anything
no bad i haven't said anything bad
like we do a six-round draft of twitter
i haven't sucked up
you take them in round four well i hope
everybody can respect that i'm very
logical person i don't i'm not a homer i
try to play like hey i just go by what i
see and feel from you know my study and
things like that but
like
this chiefs texans match up i mean talk
about like a game or yeah okay it was
back in week six i mean kansas city is
just a totally different football team
right now right i mean i just look at
them and go
all right on offense yeah they're not a
great running football team but they
found a short passing game you know of
course they make big plays they're not
as explosive as they were last year but
the defense is really the difference in
the kansas city chiefs that first
matchup the texans ran the ball had the
ball for like 39 minutes almost i think
in game game time and that just won't
happen this time around kansas city too
big up front i think they all have an
understanding of spagnolo's scheme
and to me um i think that's where it
changes a whole lot now does the texans
can the texans slow down kansas city and
that offense yes kansas city has not
been real consistent on offense they
just seem to find ways to make big plays
week after week to win games but man we
saw mahomes throw
a lot of have a lot of games down the
stretch whereas 180 yards you know three
touchdowns but nothing like where we saw
last year where every week we felt like
it was 380. you mentioned that chiefs
running game they were 23rd in rushing
yards in the nfl this season no one
reached 500 yards rushing this year
there were injuries now they had it was
that big play uh damian williams busted
loose against the vikings sure 30 yards
down and it's amazing you didn't get the
500 yards even with 90 on one play right
but you mentioned the short passing game
that that simulates it does that's
exactly what it is that andy reid will
find ways in the short passing game and
the screen game to take
up for the lack of a run game and the
other thing that you've heard me say too
is you know they will get underneath the
center a little bit more which opens up
the play action pass and things like
that but i think this is a very
very intriguing matchup too you know i i
guess you know you know you watch back
that first game too
you know desean watson him with hopkins
and if he has a healthy cast around him
i don't care how good kansas city's
defense is played they're going to pose
problems for you
one thing that billy o'brien will do
whether it's successful or not is he
will stay patient with the run and you
know a lot of times yeah that'll lead to
some favorable matchups on the outside
and he's got some weapons there the
kansas city chiefs defense over the past
six games averaging 11.5
points per game phenomenal wow that
really is
when you consider how bad the defense
was last year what did we say going into
the off-season all they have to do is
make the defense a little bit better and
they'll win the super bowl right the
defense is now
a lot better and i remember earlier in
the year you were banging the drum that
steve spagnolo needs to be more
aggressive force the issue right don't
just be conservative and let your
defense get gashed and worn out and just
down the field down the field
systematically
force the turnover
allow a touchdown put your offense back
on the field and we saw some more of
that but we also saw some of these guys
kind of gel i think that's what it is
right tyrone matthew his first year
there frank clark his first year there
and i think they've gotten to a point
where they have confidence that i i
think that's where it is you're right
when i first was complaining about that
they came out the first game or two and
actually did blitz and do those things
where i was going hey kansas city you
know you gotta you can't have this slow
death defense where your offense never
gets on the field and they did that for
a little while but then i think you're
right they kind of found their groove
within spagnolo's defense and spagnolo i
think probably figured out too you know
how to use certain guys with certain
ways you know he's evaluating as he goes
too wait oh this guy's not good at that
i shouldn't call that defense we're good
at this i should call more versions of
what we're doing so you tinker chris
jones was hurt for a while we can't
forget that but the big thing is that's
different from kansas city last year to
this year is they can stop the run they
have great size up front and they do
what you hear me always talk about which
is game plan specific game planning on
the defensive side you know spagnola's
gonna have a few defenses and a few
looks for desean watson this week where
he's gonna go
i'm not sure what the hell coverage
they're about to be in and i'm not sure
what the hell this coverage is now that
i have the ball in my hand you know
they're doubling this guy or cutting
over here or cutting over there and
that's really where uh kansas city's
really improved and what does the buy
mean for the chiefs and head coach andy
reid who coached the eagles for almost a
generation before that 22 and five after
a bye week 18 and three in the regular
season four and two in the postseason
when he has extra time to get ready and
you know
i i still am flummoxed by the fact that
the chiefs entered the season as a super
bowl favorite yeah and at some point
along the way
whether it was the emergence of the
ravens the emergence of the 49ers the
focus on the homes getting hurt
and the patriots declining like that
we we didn't have enough space
on the radar screen to focus on the fact
that the chiefs are pretty damn good
chiefs are prepared as the playoffs are
rolling around and i think they like it
that way because you don't have to worry
about guys reading their clippings to
the extent they're even our clippings
anymore and and guys are going to get a
little bit ticked off no because they're
not getting the respect that they
deserve and they got to go out and earn
it and i think it's a great it's one of
those great natural organic authentic
dynamics that can happen for a coach
where it just makes it a hell of a lot
easier for him to press the buttons on
his guys to go out there and win yeah no
i i think you're you're exactly right
and yeah it is amazing how they you know
i think really too you know down the
stretch when they were winning games
we're talking about it right now you
know they weren't winning games sexy to
where what we envisioned it to be it
wasn't like bombs away to kelsey and
tyree kill it was defense causing
turnovers it was an occasional big play
we saw special teams get involved a
number of different times but
i think they're much more accustom or
much more built for playoff football and
can win different ways as compared to
last year where it was like they had a
win throwing the ball and explosive
plays and big plays they couldn't win a
football game that's not the case
anymore you know they can do it
different ways they have more of a short
passing game the screen game you know
machole hardman returning kicks and
punts is added juice to their team that
way too and then the biggest thing is
steve spagnolo him
you know
chris jones
frank clark tyron matthew i think those
three guys alone have really changed the
kansas city defense in big ways and
they're physical and they're creative
and that's why i expect them to to beat
the houston texas what are you i know
you're you're picking them to win too
right i'm picking them to win they're
the only home team this weekend that i
am picking to win and cover
yes right uh and not by much but i think
they will win i think they will cover
and i think one of the reasons why we
haven't really paid as much attention to
the chiefs as we could or should late in
the year
we haven't had those spectacular moments
from patrick mahomes that we had last
year on one hand we're kind of used to
himself the bar is higher right for it
to make the highlight package right it's
really got to be something that makes us
go wow and when you're so used to
patrick mahomes doing great things there
isn't as much that makes us go wow and
get us to focus on him where the wow
plays are coming from lamar jackson yeah
so again that's the benefit to the
chiefs they are a more conventional team
this year than they were a year ago they
are easier to be overlooked they usually
be forgotten and i think that plays
right into their hands especially in the
run-up if they beat the texans and if
the ravens beat the titans to the afc
champions yeah i do i think it plays in
their hands too and yeah yeah you're
right i mean i think that the big thing
we've seen down the stretch is just team
football with a sprinkle of big plays
from patrick mahomes and you think about
their wins you know yeah the bears game
right on sunday night football mahomes
was great he kind of just made a play
when he had to make a play it wasn't
like just total destruction oh with the
greatest show on turf the ball looked
past his left-handed pass right like it
wasn't that but it was like a great
scramble oh look at that throw that's
pretty damn good i'm not impressed are
you taking every duty that's how we are
it's like we've seen that before do
something we haven't seen we're going to
watch that's been done too we expect it
and uh you know he had some moments like
down the stretch too where i think he'll
evaluate his play and go you know i
could play better i could make better
decisions i could have made a better
throw um
and i expect them to come out flying
early i really do i think that's a game
where i look at it and i think kansas
city we're going to look up late in the
first quarter and it's going to be 14 to
3 or something like that and they're
going to be able to play with the lead
throughout the game all right we have a
little question to resolve right here
which play was more impressive patrick
mahomes with his no look pass from last
season or desean watson this year when
and this wasn't the way they drew it up
no getting kicked in the face against
the raiders and recovering and throwing
the touchdown pass
uh which one was more impressive to you
i i think i still would go with the no
look the no look pass i just feel like
we hadn't really seen it in the his like
watson's play was amazing i'm not trying
to take anything away in that but you
know that was again
we had never seen it in a guy in the
midst of doing things we had never seen
done before and it was a big moment of
the football game too now watson's i
understand was a big moment too it was
the oakland raiders the kansas city
chiefs are playing the baltimore ravens
in that defense and that was a pretty
big moment in the football game and just
the way he did it so effortlessly and so
on point i think that's where i picked
that yeah and i think at the moment we
were just like wow i can't believe it it
was unreal we haven't seen it before
watson's play became more impressive the
following week when word came out that
he actually thought his eyeball had been
kicked out right socket which is a very
morbid thought enjoy your eggs this
morning but it's it's the fact that he
thought that right and kept going
when it happened we were wondering like
what was going on remember he laid there
forever and we couldn't figure out why
he got hurt and then finally you see the
replay a few times you start to realize
he got kicked in the face and it still
didn't matter and it was not long after
he'd been blown you know the in the
whistle in the grass call a few weeks
before that they didn't blow the whistle
this time and he proved why you
shouldn't build it almost lost his eye
in the process
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports